why does everyone come to Iceland so
wait why does everyone nicely I mean
Iceland doesn't have that many people
this is their population and this is the
number of tourists and look what's
happened in the past few years I mean
this trend is just exploded
[Music]
good I want to bite for some reason
everyone comes Iceland now like in the
past few years
like I don't know there's a graph that
explains this I feel like I should feel
like I should draw the graph on this
beach yeah I'm gonna draw this graph on
this beach not with my hands but with
animation
[Music]
this is Iceland's economy look what
happens not surprisingly in 2008 huge
crash the entire world was affected by
the meltdown but Iceland was perhaps hit
the hardest of any country because of
that the currency took a huge hit
suddenly your dollar or your euro could
stretch a lot further this a lot of
people started to come here simply
because it was much cheaper all this
talk about financial catastrophe is
getting me very stressed and I think I
need to relax a moment just a little
public service announcement whenever I
sell photos or videos of this blue
lagoon I always thought it was
exaggerated like someone had like really
tweaked the blue color corrected too
much thank you for the I'm here to
report that did you color correct too
much are you doing okay back there you
just want to take over here won't you
just take over
[Applause]
[Music]
so the financial meltdown could have
started this push for tourism but
something happens in 2010 that explodes
this trend of our airports are at a
standstill tonight as volcanic ash from
Iceland drifts across the region making
air travel too dangerous volcano whose
name nobody can pronounce adds an ass
shot into the air by Iceland's I hope
I'm saying this right volcano when the
volcano went off I actually needed to
get on a flight from Belgium to Milan
Italy and I couldn't know
but no one can fly and so there's a
bunch of these bride share Facebook
groups that are sharp like okay I'm
stranded in X place and I need to get
here and like can I find a ride so I
found someone a Belgian woman needed to
get to Milan as well and we drove
practice my French
there were like millions of passengers
who were stranded and the entire world's
attention was Iceland Iceland in this
volcano suddenly there were like news
crews showing up here and there was just
tons of footage and coverage of this
volcano in this place what this did is
it kind of put Iceland on the map of the
global consciousness in a really
significant way that it really hadn't
experienced so the graph in 2010 does
loose
dip but then it just skyrockets up even
further then there was that movie like
The Secret Life of Walter Mitty and
there's that whole scene and isolating
there's any way that we could possibly
land in Iceland that's 2012 a couple
years later
but Iceland we tell people you're going
to Iceland they're like Iceland oh my
god
I'd even get there they mirror lines
start offering these it's up to seven
day layover us for free and they're
flying from like the United States in
Europe and you want a stopover in
Iceland you have free
I spent $99 flight from Baltimore which
Iceland correct
[Music]
so what's the conclusion all this I
don't know what the conclusion is it
could be whatever you want it to be but
the conclusion is that there's just a
bunch more tourists in Iceland than
there was before the beautiful thing is
despite the fact that there are millions
of tourists here every year there's
still an abundance of beautiful majors
we're here in the winter which is a
little bit more of an off season but
even still there's a lot of tourists and
Iceland right at this moment and yet
there's a lot of places that are totally
empty and that gives me hope despite all
the financial crisis and volcano and
Walter Mitty and all that crap the real
reason why Iceland is having a boom is
because it's amazing and beautiful which
is actually what Isabel said in the
beginning so props to Isabel why did I
even make this video
[Music]
if you want to see kind of what we
actually did in Iceland where we went
and what we ate and things like that
head over to is this channel she's
publishing a Travel Guide vlog over
there and it's more detail on what we
actually did not just like the economic
wonk take on why people are going to
Iceland so over there check it out and
thanks for watching my video
[Music]